when you know you know Machine Gun Kelly
says he's in love I am the wahoo on
Tuesday Kelly posted a video on his
Instagram story of a super romantic
sushi date on the blanket covered with
roses there's a brunette woman in a
leather jacket and ripped jeans eating
while watching the pretty sunset he
captioned the clip in love finding
yourself and growing up and falling in
love and falling out of love is all
things that are meant to happen as human
while the 30 year old rapper didn't tag
megan we know the pair has seemingly
been going strong
let's break it down on Monday Kelly and
Megan were spotted holding hands and
kissing while out in Los Angeles
[Music]
my favorite line from the song is uh-oh
we already know Kelly kind of made their
relationship official when he tweeted
these lyrics from his song Bloody
Valentine which hello Megan is all over
the music video
[Music]
Megan and Brian Austin Green confirmed
their split in May after ten years of
marriage I just was kind of in love with
him right away and this is our tenth
year of marriage and our fifteenth years
together but her ex has been totally
approves of Kelly Ryan recently opened
up about their relationship on his
podcast Megan has continued working and
doing that and she met this this guy
Coulson on unset' on this film she's
working on I've never met him goes by
Machine Gun Kelly I've never met him
you know I Megan and I have talked about
him and and they're their friends at
this point and from what she's expressed
he's a really just nice genuine guy and
I trust her judgment she's always had
really good judgment
[Music]